okay I've got kind of a bummer story
it's always a little disappointing when
this stuff happens but I feel like it
also strengthens us a couple weeks ago I
came to you and I was really upfront and
I said listen we've had this Amazon
affiliate link for many many years many
of you have it bookmarked and you use it
everytime you shop to support the david
pakman show and amazon has shut the
whole thing down we lost our amazon link
and with it we lost about ten percent of
our revenue now ten percent of our
revenue alone would not be a big deal
but we were already dealing with a major
loss of revenue as a result of youtube's
the monetization that took place
starting at the end of March beginning
of April so it's been a tough 2017 it's
been our best year in terms of audience
size and growth but because of the
YouTube and Amazon stuff revenue wise
it's been a tough year for the David
Pakman show and some of you reacted
positively I got a lot of emails from
people saying David the program is good
and you will figure out the revenue
problem
I had people who became patrons pledging
money on patreon as a result of this hit
that we took people becoming members on
our website just sending positive
comments of different kinds but sadly
thousands of people thousands of people
apparently just waiting around for the
demise of the David Pakman show
literally cheered the loss of another
10% of our revenue does our audience
really have that many horrible people in
it or is it that they're overly
represented from some kind of self
selection bias the same type of bias
that makes it so that you're much more
likely to write a negative review of a
restaurant if you have a bad experience
than to write a positive review if you
had a good experience and I've got some
of these YouTube comments from the clip
on YouTube where we announced that this
took place and they are really really
bad and we're gonna put some of some of
them up on the screen Stephen Yan saying
probably because you're not a real
business to begin with a BS propaganda
show by a foreign national who should be
deported I'm an American citizen sir let
me make that clear absolutely fantastic
Pakman you are still a [ __ ] relishing
delighting in this hit that we took
another user on YouTube they
is great news that the david pakman show
has got has received a cut to a revenue
source that's a user named no face eat
more ice cream a user going by the name
eat more ice cream good for Amazon I
guess they meant good this communist
creep is nothing but a dishonest liar
david pack of lies communist foreigner
another comment looks like David Kirkman
will have to get a real job
another comment in response to bad news
a Jew begging for money lol if I have my
way you will not succeed and fortunately
despite the haters there are people who
actually realize oh hey I value the
David Pakman show
and I want the David Pakman show token
to continue so major thanks to everybody
who's gone to patreon.com slash david
pakman show which you can do anytime you
want and made a contribution there we
are now dangerously close dangerously
close to 2,100 patrons when we get to
2500 patrons we're gonna develop 12
long-form lectures from my boston
college course so you can contribute
their thanks to all the members that
have come in and of course you can go to
david pakman.com slash membership pick
your membership click the red sign up
button and on page 2 you can input the
coupon code
I voted 17 and save 40% so yeah the
haters are there they are there by the
thousands but the good news is with only
2 3 2 2 3 percent of our audience
supporting us the haters won't matter